oh you're awake
Sam equip yep you have to wait a whole
nother year to go one of these bad boys
another year I woke up too early
put me back in the coma man are
you the Easter Bunny actually used to be
now I'm the Atheist rabbit everything
you thought you know about Easter is
lies fat Sal you're so cool
I am yeah you know it's not cool the
McRib only being available for a limited
time well the Big Mac is available
year-round yes it's not like he was made
out of atoms Big Mac she was made out of
his McCrea something I need to show you
what you so bad I just can't the
President passed a bunch of wacky laws
now that a man can marry a male revenue
show
[Applause]
[Music]
you